the end of a carefully orchestrated coup
gabon's Junta leader pris oligi and
guemma entering the presidential Palace
to a crowd of dignitaries as if elected
by the people after deposing president
Bongo last Wednesday
is sworn in as what's being called the
president of transition
cannons are fired a reminder that the
military is now in charge
we have taken power without force or
Bloodshed and changed the regime that
was in place a regime that had taken
hostage the Republican institutions for
many years in complete disregard to
democracy
for the juntas supporters hope of a new
beginning for Gabon a ceremony in sharp
contrast to the 2017 presidential
election that saw Bongo extend the
family's dynastic rule to more than half
a century
the issue here is not legitimacy he's in
the best place to make the changes
needed let's see if we can act on what
he says
we hope for a bit of day but I can't say
just yet what that will look like we're
waiting to see what he actually does
oligi promised a referendum on a new
Constitution and free and fair elections
but gave no timeline on how long he
plans to stay in power this small
oil-rich nation is a key Ally to France
the French company total has been
operating here for nearly 90 years
French political Elites have been
accused of using gabon's state coffers
to finance politics in France
after Mali Guinea Burkina Faso and Niger
Gabon is the latest former French
African colony to experience Aku and a
rejection of how democracy has played
out since Independence
there's a very clear desire being
expressed in these countries to turn the
page but once again the attributes of
French power are still there and France
still has allies African allies who play
to its interests and that constitutes
France afrique from Paris oligi is
perceived as an ally for now the coup
was necessary he says to bring the
country that had strayed away from
democracy back to a path led by not one
family but the gabonese people
Nicholas Hawk Al Jazeera